This is the payroll recording for pay period Monday November 10th 2025 to Sunday November 16th 2025.
Starting off here with the Monday AM shift, it's John Neal.
No Busser or Expo.
Total tips and fees, this is the final number, $70.09.
Again, that's $70.09.
Okay, Monday PM shift.
Austin Kelly, and this is going to be before tip-out, so we need to subtract Coban's tip-out from this number.
Kelly did $164.82 in total tips and fees, and we need to subtract out $21.02 for Coban Cross, who was the utility guy.
Next is Tuesday November 11th, this is the AM shift.
No Busser or Expo or utility.
So, Brooks final tips should be $39.65.
Tuesday November 11th 2025 PM shift, it was Kevin and Janelle.
And these are the final numbers, Kevin and Janelle each made $88.59.
Coban Cross needs to make $25.05.
Okay, now Wednesday AM shift.
No utility, the server was John Neal, and his final tips were $176.69.
And now on to the Wednesday November 12th 2025 PM shift.
It was Austin Kelly.
No utility guy, total tips and fees were $164.14.
Again, that's $164.14.
Okay, so the utility guy was Coban Cross on this one, so we need to do that math.
So, Austin Kelly before tip out made $164.14, and we need to subtract $23.85 as Coban's tip out.
He was the utility guy.
Okay, on to Thursday November 13th 2025, this is the AM shift.
It was Austin Kelly solo with no expo, bus or utility guy.
So this is the final number $160.92.
Now on to Thursday PM, again November 13th 2025, Austin Kelly was the server.
Maddox was the utility guy.
This is the before tip out number for Austin, so we need to do the calculation.
Before tip out, Austin Kelly made $253.93.
Then he needs to tip out Maddox Porter, $27.39.
Now on to Friday November 14th, this is the AM shift.
It was Austin Kelly with no utility guy.
Scratch that, I'm totally starting over on Friday November 11th 2025.
This is the AM shift.
It was Austin Kelly and the utility guy was Maddox Porter.
So before tip out, Austin Kelly made $202.86.
Then we need to do the calculation and subtract out $29.92 for the utility guy, which again was Maddox Porter.
Friday PM shift, these are the final numbers.
So this is after tip out.
Kevin, $207.41. Austin, $207.41.
Utility was Maddox, $59.61.
Saturday November 15th 2025 AM shift, these are the final numbers.
So after tip out, Kevin Worley, $255.85. Mark, $255.85.
Utility was Coban, $66.59.
Saturday November 15th 2025 PM shift, these are the final numbers.
Kevin, $165.44. Mark, $165.44. Coban, $52.72.
Again, those are all final numbers.
Okay, Sunday November 16th 2025.
This is the AM shift.
These are final numbers. So these are final numbers.
Kevin, $196.93. Mike, $196.93. Coban, $66.24.
Sunday November 16th 2025 PM shift, these are the final numbers.
Kevin, $105.76. Austin, $105.76. Coban, $31.30.
Again, those are all final numbers.